rebel wilson makes this pride month one
to remember revealing she's dating
fashion designer ramona agruma
and e.t has the details behind this
sweet new romance it's like love is in
the air on thursday the actress shared
this selfie cuddled up to the fashion
designer and in the caption rebel writes
i thought i was searching for a disney
prince but maybe what i really needed
all this time was a disney princess
hashtag love is love well when you wish
upon a star rebel
you know she wasn't joking about the
whole prince princess thing either check
out this pick from earlier this year
yeah it is a total fairy tale romance
i'm really excited
after rebels posed a source confirmed to
et that the pick was in fact a
relationship reveal adding quote they
are very happy together and their
friends are so supportive of their
relationship and thrilled for them and
those supportive friends showed out on
social media
super emotional
rebels pitch perfect co-star anna
kendrick dropped into the comments with
love you both like crazy while jojo
siwa's girlfriend kylie prue shared a
series of omgs with rainbow themed
emojis
and over on twitter krishell stouse
joined in on the celebration on a tweet
about rebels news the selling sunset
star who just revealed she's part of the
lgbtq plus community replied with a row
of harsh themed emojis it's amazing
it's amazing
so who's the new love in rebel's life
here's what we know ramona is a law
school grad turned fashion entrepreneur
she founded lemon v limon which
advertises itself as a sustainable
clothing brand based in los angeles as
for how these two found each other rebel
played coy in a recent podcast interview
sharing only that they were set up by a
mutual friend you gotta keep hustling
guys
also ramona might look familiar to
rebels followers on top of their day at
disney ramona's made it to the grid
quite a bit this year
here's rebel arriving at vanity fair's
oscar party and here's ramona helping
her gf get ready to hit the carpet
ramona also just might be a sports fan
judging by this pick of the two hanging
out at the super bowl with james corden
[Music]